hubert ne vaut pas le meilleur je vous
répondrai oui ce serait de la prétention
je vous répondrais non ça serait la
bêtise que savez vous de l'afrique
les africains sont joyeux sympathique
rigolard ce sont nos amis qui font nos
frères quasiment et ensuite nous jugeons
pas tous là bas les mines de diamants
les puits de pétrole le gaz et l'uranium
nos amis africains sont très tendues
pour le dossier ne se sont pas
respectées ni traiter d'égal aig
bonjour monsieur van damme à eau qu'est
ce que vous faites là je suis proche de
vos valises
c'est mon travail mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces préjugés rassuré le
président mes respects monsieur le
président mon ami j'aime la france et
votre musique
c'est quand même autre chose que cette
entame insupportable je sens qu'on va
bien s'entendre
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas entendu et sont
susceptibles et et il faut prendre des
gants qui ça il fonctionne une heure
aucun malentendu je n'ai pas en ce
moment harry voit du racisme partout
vous faites ceci en france ah non il ya
beaucoup moins noir qu ici et c'est
dommage d'ailleurs
[Musique]
vous voulez représenter la tête pensante
du 11 septembre mohamedou ould slahi les
mauritaniens détenus à guantanamo il a
recruté les types qui ont envoyé l'avion
de votre ami dans la tour sud
[Applaudissements]
nous ne sommes pas là pour des
interrogatoires nous travaillons
absolument pas pour le gouvernement
américain sait j'ai su qu'on vous êtes
rentrée les interrogateurs n'ont pas
peur des trésoriers on va réclamer la
peine de mort mais si on omet un petit
détail il sera libéré le gouvernement
américain retient 700 prisonniers
attendent en amont depuis quand on
enferme les gens sans leur accorder le
procès dans ce pays ça fait un paquet de
dossiers
oui le gouvernement à quatre ans
d'avancé sur nous
depuis que je suis ici on n'a cessé de
me dire tu es coupable
pas pour quelque chose que j'aurais fait
à cause de soupçons
le bureau du procureur refuse de nous
montrer les charges d'accusation tout
est censuré
problème est allé voir le gouvernement
je suis innocent il a été interrogé il a
été également retenu contre son gré
pendant six ans sans aucune charge
valable contre lui
ça ne nous perturbe pas de défendre un
terroriste n'est pas seulement lui que
je défends c'est la règle de droit
vous n'avez pas vu ce que j'ai vu
peut-être qu'il est coupable peut-être
oui
vous devez me dire tout ce que vous avez
subi sinon je ne pourrais pas vous
défendre et que vous comprenez vous
demander de mettre le feu ici mais moi
je suis toujours coincés ici ce n'est
pas un suspect c'est un témoin je viens
d'un pays où on n'a aucune confiance en
la police jamais je n'aurais imaginé que
les états unis d'amérique utiliserait la
peur et la terreur pour me contrôler
[Musique]
salut ils ont mis des kalachnikovs pour
faire les brutes
tu sais qui était sur mon blog elle nous
dit mme pétroliers en mer et connecte
toi vite
on part demain on se prépare pour le
délire
pourquoi les soldats vous ont-ils
attaqué faut qu'on trouve un moyen de
prouver
pichette mais l'écart
mais ce qui fait les bars
tous les signaux sont au vert j'ai
oublié de retour pour la suède
vous les terroristes ou pas condamné à
11 ans de prison
j'occupe
ne faites confiance à personne qu'est ce
qui nous dit qu'on peut faire confiance
à temps
ils vont me tuer
et on sait tous le fruit défendu à
meilleur coût
souci
[Musique]
je vais enfin faire la connaissance des
zones ouais tu vas voir marais qui est
tous les autres super quoi ça 21h45
allez mon pass verte allongé il va faire
un petit somme
angelica
et ce suis tombé amoureux de bézieux
fascinant c'est peut-être ma femme je
suis désolé c'est pas grave on continue
à faire avec
il est où le gars qui va payer pour les
pizzas
qui a tué marais
[Musique]
ce qu'on aimerait c'est avoir un peu de
sexe
patience
permettez moi que vous présentez le
prodigieux nikola tesla
le plus grands inventeurs de tous les
temps si vous recherchez nikola tesla
sur google vous aurez dont 4 millions de
résultat ce sont toujours les quatre
mêmes photos en dehors de ça les autres
images sont plus étranges et créative et
maintenant j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter un nouveau système de
distribution d'énergie
le courant alternatif vous travailler de
nuit dans un laboratoire secret vous
envoyez des éclairs depuis la terre vers
le ciel le courant alternatif est une
perte de temps
c'est très peu pratique et dangereux
vous avez du feu
[Musique]
va transformer la façon dont le monde
fonctionne
vous vivez dans votre tête ce n'est pas
le cas de tout le monde
[Musique]
le membre dans lequel on vit
est un rêve que nikola tesla arrivé en
premier
[Musique]
mes rêves sont déjà réalité tous les
super héros sont animés par un seul but
sauver ceux qui en ont besoin
ils ont une autre chose en commun on me
les croise jamais dans le monde réel
sophie lee
tous les super-héros une mission dans ce
monde
ne le voit pas toujours tout de suite
parce qu'on ne sait pas toujours où
regarder
flora qu'est ce que c'est que ça je suis
ulysse revenu à l'aise sacré nom d'une
manifestation inattendu c'est toi qui a
écrit ça c'est un super héros en quoi tu
as des ennemis toi je viens pour
l'écureuil tu sais le danger se cachent
partout
vival
police nous a ouvert les yeux
le monde est rempli de magie et de
merveilles
enfin ici
appuie maintenant allez quoi d'ulysse
même dans les heures les plus sombres un
véritable héros sera prêts à tout
risquer pour sauver le monde qui mêle
est-ce que tu parles oui d'accord c'est
pas tout à fait ça mais si c'est moi